foreign
I think oh I want to play you
25 000 years old demarcel kind of
quietly behind the scenes running things
being Sly Lara does it so well I don't I
don't want to touch it but I think
um I think it'd be fun trying to
understand what it's like to be a robot
and she navigates that performance so
beautifully oh if I can play any
character it it would probably be
Dawn changes a lot
of the way the nature of the cleons
Cassian who plays Dawn gets to do so
many things as an actor and that's
really exciting the emperor of the
Galaxy very simple
you know like openly okay all right
I mean the obvious answer is the prime
meridian I think in some way that the
vault is more impressive than the prime
rating
there's like a device in season one
where
um you can kind of put this laser thing
over something and just fix it
that's our four uses um on the Invictus
and I I think that's a great thing that
I would love to have but I do like the
the bracelet the protective all right
I'm so clumsy okay tripping for all the
time and I get bruises all the time so I
probably would save myself from all of
that if I had one of those
well I think I already did do you trust
the mask I definitely could not win a
galaxy-wide math contest there's no way
that Harry Selden would ever pick me as
a prodigy
um no not in that I uh I really suck at
math I reckon I could win a galaxy-wide
math contest if it was trigonometry
I actually hilariously used to do that
as a hobby just like solve trigonometry
when I was younger
[Music]
wouldn't we all like to mind read think
that would save me a lot of time I
definitely nerded out on the fact that
the prime radiant we explain is a
Quantum device that's in a state of
superposition which means it can sort of
be in two places at once I love that I
love that the ball is a tesseract
meaning it's bigger on the inside than
it is on the outside because I think
that's really mind-blowing and I love
where that mind takes me I sure would
love to have a Bishop's claw that I
could just ride and that would defend me
if anyone attacked me I think that one's
pretty cool
see yeah this is the question this is
the question this is the question I hope
so
isn't that where we're headed
I don't know you guys tell me
no definitely not uh we should all be
scared of AI I think we probably can
exist peacefully but we're gonna have to
compromise on some things I reckon it's
so complicated and also you I mean you
look at it happening right now I know
people who look at their phones more
than they look at their spouse the
beautiful thing about like communicating
with a human is that you always have to
take a risk that you don't know how the
other person is going to communicate
with you kind of like falling in love
it's always a risk
easy